we know that Thanos is Infinity Gauntlet
is going to be making a return in
Avengers endgame the only question is
just what's going to happen with it will
one of the heroes manage to take the
Infinity Gauntlet and use its incredible
power for themselves here's why these
superheroes might wear the Infinity
Gauntlet in endgame if there's one
character you actually want to see
control in the Infinity stones and the
omnipotent power that goes along with
them it's Steve Rogers the guy who
always does the right thing in the
marijuana we may not be perfect but the
safest hands are still our own if he got
his hands on the gauntlet then it's easy
to see how all that death and
destruction at the end of infinity war
could be corrected could set things
right again
even if there was a huge cost to doing
so which they almost certainly would be
when Thanos uses the Infinity Gauntlet
at the end of infinity war we'd see that
the gullet itself has burnt out and
damaged nearly shattered by the forces
that a channel that's no mean feat
considering that it was crafted by the
same dwarves who crafted me onea which
took a literal goddess of death to break
Thanos survive the gollnitz power surge
but he's also an incredibly powerful
Titan Captain America can run faster
than a luxury vehicle leap off rooftops
and a bicep curl a helicopter and he's a
moral fiber that holds the Avengers
together
language his indomitable will with no
doubt given the ability to use a
gauntlet but surviving it is a different
question the backlash in controlling
those forces and then winding time to
make things right would give him the
perfect opportunity for the heroic
sacrifice that would bring the character
to the end that Chris Evans and the
Russo brothers have been hinting at Tony
Stark might not seem like the prime
candidate to wear the gauntlet but if
you think about it he fits wait for it
like a glove
after all for all its mystical sci-fi
trappings the gauntlet is just another
piece of technology and technology is
Iron Man special day when did you become
an expert in thermonuclear astrophysics
last night all this happened in the
comic books all right a he's actually
the first human in the Marvel Universe
to wield the gauntlet a relatively
recent events that happened in the pages
of Avengers in 2011 one of the most
interesting things about that is what
Tony does with there he creates an
illusion of the gauntlet being destroyed
but then secretly hands off the stones
to the people he trusts most of course
all that stuff about heroic sacrifice
still applies to Tony and this may give
us a fond farewell to Robert Downey jr.
allowing Jim Rhodes to step into the
armor as the new Iron Man Christmas
playing the most likely character to
where the Infinity Gauntlet an endgame
it might also be the most surprising at
least for MCU fans who haven't checked
out the source material Thanos his
daughter nebula played a critical role
to the Infinity Gauntlet storyline in
the comics and given what happened to
Gamora in infinity war she has a
personal motivation too in the original
Infinity Gauntlet storyline follows his
murder of half the universe isn't his
climactic goal it's his opening move
when they're surviving heroes head out
to the edge of the universe that owes
brutally destroys them one by one
all the while nebula is there watching
it trapped in a desiccated corpse and
kept on the edge of life and death just
to amuse Santos there is however enough
consciousness left in her that she's
able to eventually steal the gauntlet
when Thanos abandons his body and shifts
a timeline back by 24 hours before Fano
snapped his fingers and killed off the
heroes if the movies go a similar way
that could add a very personal element
to the struggle against Thanos
in the movies nebula has been tortured
her entire life her body replaced piece
by piece with cybernetics as part
for her failures leaving her in the
disassembled state that we've seen
infinity war
she's already vowed to hunt him down and
return the favor until he knows some
semblance of the profound and unceasing
pain I know every single yeah not only
that but Gamora the sister who tried to
protect her was murdered by Thanos
if Gamora stays dead nebulas vengeance
on Thanos would be very satisfying and
could even set her up to join the
Guardians bonding with star-lord over
the loss of Gamora well you should have
killed me would have been waste of parts
Bruce Banner might just be the most
compelling choice to get control of the
Infinity Gauntlet an end game since Thor
Ragnarok we've seen the Hulk at war with
his alter ego and an infinity war that
was compounded when the greener side of
banners personality refused to come out
and fights even when the world was at
stake
duder embarrass me from the Wizards if
bana does take control of the gauntlets
he might use it to finally find the
harmony between the warring factions of
a psyche that he's been looking for
since he was created that could give us
another element of the comics a unified
version of the Hulk who has a
gamma-powered body of the green Goliath
and the brilliant mind of Bruce Banner
we could get quite a bit out of the idea
of banner controlling the Infinity
Gauntlet including a chance for Mark
Ruffalo to do some hulk acting that
wasn't limited to mono syllables and
smashing i smash you - washer baby lumps
what the god of thunder arms with both
the unstoppable Stormbreaker and the
Infinity Gauntlet is pretty much the
definition of overpowered we'll admit
that this seems like a pretty unlikely
scenario but believe it or not something
similar happened in the comics way back
in 2000 store issue 25 the god of
thunder took on Thanos in one of the
most brutal fights to hit the comics
page while Thanos was winning her first
thought geared up with a whole new set
of mystical artifacts enchanted by Odin
and wound up beating the purple out of
the mad Titan until he was facedown in
the Asgardian turts unlikely yes but
also pretty rad Loki in case you forgot
is dead he was killed in the opening
scenes of infinity war murdered by
Thanos after trying to save the brother
he spent so much of his time luring into
our larious stabbings he transformed
himself into a snake and he knows how I
love snakes so I went to pick up the
snake to admire it and he transformed
back into himself and he was like yeah
it's me have any stunned me that said
death has never exactly stopped Loki
before so why would it be a problem now
coming back from the dead is what the
dude does and the last second revival
and the theft of the Infinity Gauntlet
might just tip the scales in the end
game you're like I believe this one but
it kind of happened before in the comics
kinda in the original Infinity Gauntlet
comic Thanos is paired up with Mephisto
a demon who eventually portrays him the
thing is Mephisto doesn't currently
exist in the MCU instead at the role of
a lackey who eventually betrayed Sano's
has actually fallen to Loki
plus we already know that there's a Loki
TV show in developments with Tom
Hiddleston attached to star unless it's
a prequel he's deaf
coming back in some form or another if
he gains control of the Infinity
Gauntlet and somehow manages to resist
the corrupting influence of absolute
power that could complete the shift in
his character from unrepentant villain
to DBS antihero exactly what he needs to
be if he's going to be a protagonist
from here on out the trailer for endgame
is relentlessly depressing full of stuff
like Tony Stark recording his final
message to pepper Steve Rogers shedding
tears over the fate of his friends and
Clint Barton looking haunted in the rain
that is until the very end when the
ant-man shows up and suddenly things are
as goopy as they've ever been at me can
you buzz me in Scott Lang getting his
hands on the Infinity Gauntlet would be
pretty shocking but it's not entirely
unlikely the entire Marvel Universe is
about the little guy managing to triumph
over impossible odds in both the
figurative and literal sense there's no
little a guide in ant-man it's also his
chance to actually save the world one of
the fun things about the ant-man of
films that they have smaller stakes on
the rest of the MCU getting him involved
in something this big would be weird and
wild enough to be really fun check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]